tenemos aquí esta expresión peliaguda
pero en realidad lo único que queremos
hacer es dividir estos dos números
complejos
este número complejo en azul y este
número complejo en verde de hecho ya nos
los graficaron por acá así que veamos
ustedes puede notar que estos de hecho
los dos números están en forma polar y
veamos el ángulo del primer número del
número azul es siete puntos así que
salimos de el eje real positivo y nos
movemos nos lo vemos hasta acá ese es el
ángulo y luego estamos a distancia 7 el
origen así que 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 y llegamos
a este punto
así que este es mi primer número
complejo este número de aquí
y el segundo número complejo es un
número que tiene argumento que tiene
ángulos 7p y cuartos así que salimos de
aquí
y giramos hasta llegar a este punto y
estamos a distancia 1 del origen de
hecho podemos pensar que esto tiene un
número 1 aquí adelante muy bien ahora
nos piden divididos y como siempre los
invito a ponerle pausa al vídeo y tratar
de en primer lugar dividir estos dos
números complejos y también graficar los
pero bueno asumo que ya lo hicieron así
que comencemos lo primero que pueden
notar es que quizás esta expresión que
se ve bastante horrenda igual y sería
más fácil manejarla en la forma
exponencial de los números complejos y
para hacer eso lo que tenemos que hacer
es notar
que este cacho el cacho que está aquí
entre paréntesis es igual a cuánto pues
si utilizamos la fórmula de hoy leer la
famosísima fórmula de oyler podemos
notar que esto que está entre paréntesis
es igual a
por 7 y sextos siguiente
a las 7 y sextos por y el elevado a las
7 x sextos por y así que todo este
número azul en se podría escribir como 7
meses
a las 7 y sextos
7 textos word
y que hay del número que está abajo el
denominador pues estamos dividiendo
entre
por de hecho no tendría que escribir el
1 pero bueno uno por qué lo escribo
mejor
por e a las siete y cuarto por i
siete cuartos
por fin
y ahora podemos utilizar las propiedades
de los exponentes para reducir esto
cuanto nos haría si reduzco esto pues 7
entre 1 es simplemente 7
y ahora pongo la en la base de la
exponencial a qué potencia pues voy a
simplemente a restarle esta potencia a
esta otra así que va a ser va a ser 7 p
en 36 x
menos
- 7 p
entre 4 por iu y ahora sólo se trata de
reducir esta fracción reducir esta
fracción de aquí vamos a
tener más espacio
y cuánto es cuánto es siete y sextos
pues
déjenme de una vez lo hago vamos a
escribir esta resta con denominador
común de 12 entonces 7 pieces extras es
lo mismo que 14 pie
14 pi entre 12 y voy a multiplicarlo por
y ya eso le tengo que restar
tengo que restar 7 entre 4 con
denominador 12 que sería 7 por 3 21 21
entre 12
cuánto es esto pues pongo mi denominador
común que 12 14 - 21 es menos 7 así que
todo esto sería menos 7 por fin
entre 12 porque así que este número es
igual a
al menos 7
entre 12
por y perdón y el 7
se me olvidaba este 7 de aquí ok
entonces ahora sólo es cuestión de
graficar este número es un número que
tiene argumento menos 7 pide entre 12
así que es algo de aquí
el eje real positivo y me muevo -7 piña
/ 12 cada uno de estos pequeños arcos 6
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 y aquí ya
estoy en vías y que cada cada uno de
estos pequeños fallos que está marcando
un ángulo de d
entre 12 así que para llegar a menos 7 y
entre 12 me muevo de aquí menos 1 - 2 -
3 - 4 15 menos seis menos siete y con
este ángulo me alejo siete unidades del
origen uno dos tres cuatro cinco seis
y llegaría a este punto de ese sería el
número complejo que resulta de dividir
estos dos números y observen como me
tuve que mover conforme a las manecillas
del reloj porque mi ángulo era negativo
si el ángulo es positivo nuevo contra
las manecillas del reloj y si el ángulo
es negativo
el nuevo conforme a las manecillas del
reloj pero bueno entonces el resultado
de dividir este número complejo entre
este otro número complejo es éste el
número complejo que dibuje aquí en
magenta y por supuesto si quisiera no
escribir esto en forma polar es también
muy sencillo y es perfectamente válido
esto sería lo mismo que 7 una magnitud
por el coseno coseno de menos 7 pie
entre 12 y 7 entre 12
más veces el seno
de -7 pido
entre todos
estos dos números complejos son
exactamente iguales